بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته يسرني نرحب بكم جميعا
في جده في ختام اعمال القمه العربيه
العاديه في دورتها 32 والتي تراسها اليوم
سيدي صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن سلمان نيابه
عن خادم الحرمين الشريفين حفظهم الله
بحضور اشقائه اصحاب الجلاله فخامه والسمو
قاده الدول الاعضاء
حيث ناقش اصحاب الجلاله كذا واضح حيث ناقش
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ابرز
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه المتعلقه
بالعالم العربي ولا التوسع امن الدول
الاعضاء وصالحها المشتركه واسفر عن القمه
اعلان جده تاكيدا على اهميه تعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك بما يسهم في حشد الطاقات
والقدرات لصناعه مستقبل قائم على الابداع
والابتكار
[موسيقى]
ان الابداع والابتكار
ومواكب التطورات المختلفه بما يسهم في
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار وتضمن اعلان جده
متابعه التطورات والاحداث والجهريه
في جمهوريه السودان
وضروره وقف الاقتتال لعوده الامن
والاستقرار وحمايه الشعب السوداني كما تم
التاكيد على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
واهميه ايجاد حل قائمه على تطبيق قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه
ومبادره السلام العربيه وتم الترحيب
بالقرار الصادر عن اجتماع مجلس الجامعه
المستوى الوزاري والذي تضمن استئنافي
مشاركه رفوفه الحكومه السوريه في اجتماعات
مجلس الجامعه والمنظمات والاجهزه التابع
لها ونامل ان يرسم ذلك في دعم استقرار
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه والحفاظ على
وحده اراضيها واستئناف دورها الطبيعي في
الوطن العربي وتضمن الاعلان عدد من
المؤادرات التي من شانها ان تسموا بداء
فعل العمل العربي المشترك في المجالات
الثقافيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والبيئيه وابرزها مبادره استدامه سلاسل
امداد السلع الغذائيه الاساسيه للدول
العربيه
فكريه للبحوث والدراسات والاستلام
والتنميه الاقتصاديه ونؤمن من الرؤى
والخطط القائمه على استثمار الموارد
والفرص ومعالجه التحديات قادره على توطين
التنميه بما يتطلبه من ترسيخ التضامننا
وتعزيز وترابطنا ووحدتنا لتحقيق طموحات
وتضرعات شعوبنا العربيه ومن هنا فان انا
ايضا نرحب برساله الفخامه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ورساله الرئيس الصيني
الموجه الى القمه كما اننا استمعنا الى
كلمه فخامه الرئيس الاوكراني
الذي حضر بدعوه من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لهذه القمه واتقدم الجزيره الشكر
للجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
على مبادرته من جهود كبيره خلال قيادتها
الاعمال الدور الماضيه الحادي والثلاثين
ولا تتكللت ولله الحمد بالنجاح والان
يسرني ان اعطي الكلمه الاخيره العام
فليتفضل معاليه
شكرا شكرا صاحب السمو
في البدايه
ينبغي ان الانسان يعبر عن عميق الشكر
لخادم الحرمين
الشريفين
ويعبر عن عميق الشكر للاداره المتميزه
لصاحب السمو الملكي محمد الامير محمد بن
سلمان
المملكه
بذلت جهدا طيبا للغايه ووضعت الكثير من
الموارد والامكانيات في خدمه هذه القمه
والحقيقه حققت الهدف المطلوب منها تماما
القمه اتصفت بصفه يعني انا مضى عليها عده
قمم الان هذه ربما القمه السادسه او
السابعه لكن هذه القمه اتصفت
بصفه واضحه للغايه وهو التوافق اللي قبل
القمه وخلال عمليات القمه
في خلاصتها الاجتماعات
كانت اجتماعات سلسه وهادئه
لعل الجميع لاحظها انه القمه ماسترختش
فتره طويله في بحث هذه القرارات ولا
الاجتماع الوزاري ولا حتى اجتماعات
المندوبين
القمه صدر عنها بعض القرارات الهامه
اهمها في تقديري هو القرار الخاص بعوده
سوريا له رمزيه واضحه للغايه
اتصالا بموضوع عوده سوريا
فوضح لي شخصيا ان هناك رغبه وعزم اكيد ان
تكون عوده سوريا بدايه لانخراط عربي اكثر
فاعليه
في حل لازمه السوريه
واستعادت سوريا لدورها الطبيعي في
المنظومه العربيه
وتجاوز الظروف الصعبه التي مرت بهذا البلد
العزيز علينا جميعا نحن عرب
وبالتالي
سوريا تحتاج لمساعده اخواتها
وهي في نفس الوقت
ينبغي ان تتفاعل مع هذه الخطوه التي قامت
بها المجموعه العربيه
الازمات العربيه احتلت مكانا مهما على
اجنده هذه القمه
هناك
شعور واضح انه العرب يرغبون في امتلاك
ناصيه التفاعل والتعامل مع المشكلات
العربيه وعدم تركها اطلاقا
للقوى الاجنبيه او الاقليميه
هناك ايضا احساس
بحاله من الهدوء مع الجوار العربي
ومن يرصد القرارات الصادره عن القمه في
علاقات الجوار العربي مع
دول العربيه يجد ان هناك تهدئه
والقمه والجانب العربي بيطرح التهدئه
وينبغي ان تلتقط الخيط
دولتي تركيا
وايران تحديدا لانه كان هناك قرارات
وتم تهدئه هذه القرارات
اعطاء الفرصه
لدول الجوار لبدء صفحه جديده
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت على راس النقاشات
ووضحت في كافه
التدخلات والقرارات الصادره عنها وهناك
تمسك
بمبادره السلام العربيه وهناك جاهد
بذلته المملكه منذ سبتمبر الماضي
شاركت في الجامعه العربيه
وذهبنا الى نيويورك وعقدنا اجتماعات مع
المجموعه الاوروبيه مع الدول الدائمه
العضويه في كيفيه الاحتفاء بمبادره السلام
وبمناسبه مرور 20 عاما عليها ثم عدنا مره
اخرى الى بروكسيل وهناك رغبه اكيده في
تنشيط
التحرك في اطار مبادره السلام العربيه
الموضوعات الاقتصاديه لقيت اهتمام ومن
يتابع هذه القرارات يجد انها فعلا يعني
قرارات الصادره عن القمه انه انه الموضوع
البعد الاقتصادي والاجتماعي بيعظه باهتمام
كبير
في
الخلاصه اود القول ان هناك حيويه وحركيه
جديده في العالم العربي
نتطلع جميعا بان تكون هذه القمه قمه جده
بدايه لان ياخذ العرب امورهم بايديهم
ويتحركوا باراده جماعيه لتسويه الازمات
القائمه في المنطقه العربيه
الحقيقه المنطقه العربيه مرت
ربما عقد كامل
من الصعوبات
وهي في طريقها او امل انها في طريقها الى
الخروج من هذه الصعوبات فكل
الخير وانصح الجميع باعلان بقراءه اعلان
جده باهتمام لانه من
يطلع على القرار على الاعلان
هيجد
في صدر
الاعلام القضايا الفلسطينيه وده شيء
يعني اللي اعدوا هذا الاعلان كان لديهم
اقتناع كامل به حيويه هذه القضيه خصوصا في
هذا التوقيت تحديدا الذي يضغط الجانب
الاسرائيلي بكل التشدد وبكل العدوانيه
وبكل التطرف على الفلسطينيين شكرا جزيلا
سمو الامير على كل شيء